I guess the key things are gonna extract
that they help me of my lifting one was
developing a process for when I'm
lifting so a routine that I go through
every single time before a lift in order
to develop consistency and also it's
better carryover any performance that I
did in training into an environment like
a major championships because commonly
see athletes that can do by weighing in
the gym put them on a platform we go do
something different or lose their rhythm
and don't actually deliver on the day so
they told me to help them develop
process and the second thing was only
that worrying about the things that I
could control like so again that
outcomes were there just byproducts of
whatever the process was so um I guess
those two things are going is too much
death really helped me can you can you
explain what your process is yeah for
you do a lift okay and this is some of
this really independent to everyone and
I think the sooner you become aware of
your individual process the better
chance you've got then of obviously
being consistent so for me I paced up
and down the bar back and forth I stand
back behind the bar and I like to call
my pink box so this is where I am
thinking about the to the technical side
of things that my coach has taught me
whether it's to stay over keep the bar
close etc my technical cues there and I
visualize myself and this is always a
good question because people was asset
do you visualize watching myself or in
my own body yeah so I visualize watching
myself do it and executing the lift and
it being a great lift and yeah so after
that then I approach the bar and that's
when my like that's my trigger then to
just go through my routine so my routine
is always right hand first
then left hand and then set my feet I
shake my arms I've get my breathing
controlled I start counting them three
five four three two one mutter it very
quietly under my breath when I hit one I
lock in and go and for me like I always
used to have that issue which load of
probably the listener
well as well and anyone just wait the
thing right before you come off the 40
thing far this is gonna be happy yeah
well you laugh because you know exactly
what going on about and that doesn't
change whether you're in limbic apathy
or it's your first day you go [ __ ] this
can be happy or I might hurt myself here
but again they're negative outcomes like
of one of your processes and for me just
by counting down before I left and going
like one like a gunshot
erase it distracts your mind from
thinking about those negative thoughts
that worked really well for me so yeah
that's that and that's the same for both
snatch and clean and jerk yeah okay and
what about exact always I've always
wondered this once you count to one and
once the movement has begun do you just
let the training kick in in the same way
as a boxer doesn't think too much but
there must be a point in snatch I can
see that it's one more fluid movement
yeah there must be a moment once you've
cleaned the bar and then you stand on is
that same thing but short version of it
so I get out the top and the theme my
foot comes in further away my heels
three two one bang so this is that the
same thing broken stick that's awesome
yeah that's a lovely little framework
for people to use and it sounds so
stupid that I've stepped up to the bar
like in workouts or even like going for
Mike's lifts and I've just like
approached the bar like gripped it a
whole bridge for the best but I don't
have it I don't have a process and
that's why you won't get consistency
yeah again to draw the